she was the girl of my dreams that was
the moment I knew that it was done we
met three years ago you are a league of
their own right Gauri
excellent what is your favorite drink
grapefruit juice with vodka and three
maraschino cherries hey you want to get
out of here yeah it was the perfect
first date but I waited too long and
then I got hug death oh this is so nice
to have a good guy friend I can't even
tell you
[Music]
I'm in love with a tree only I could go
back and do it with you differently I
could be the guy guys you may want could
you tell me what year it is it's the
2014 I just traveled back in time right
now I have someone to meet what's your
favorite drink
mine is grapefruit juice with vodka and
exactly three maraschino cherries
that's my favorite drink juice what this
is the psycho I was telling you about
you didn't guess that I was an army brat
you already knew that you're a stalker
soccer's or we're like trench coats and
no underwear and I am clearly wearing
underwear look the photo booth is a time
machine
this is gonna be the best night of your
life I can deal with best night of my
life follow what I do ready if What's Up
Girl What's Up Girl ha are you doing a
Joker impersonation this is no this is
like it was good all else fails be an
[ __ ] be an [ __ ] not hard [ __ ]
soft [ __ ]
don't forget your leather pants oh my
god I went full [ __ ]
I have no control over any of this I'd
make a decision and then I wake up three
years later with the consequences I
thought things were supposed to happen
for a reason things happen for no reason
at all but they create opportunities the
question is can you recognize that next
opportunity when it matters the most
[Music]
oh I'm gonna Bob shut up long
I got about it's it's fine I'm sorry my
bomb threat ruin your magic or even
didn't have a great life
[Music]
you